KANNAN LAKMEEHARAN >> I think-ah-the economy
in 2009 will not recover as long as each government
takes its own steps without consulting others.
It is important to have a dialog between nations.
I think some of the issues also are not just
about how we recover about spending but also
how we ought to live our lives. Ah-we have
to on the fundamental re-think. It's not sustainable.
Ah-and as--
MYRIAM LAKMEEHARAN >> It's like the leaders
said this morning, we are all in this together.
KANNAN LAKMEEHARAN >> Yeah. So I think those
are the issues. So it's-all the answers to
questions that have been put to us at the
Davos debate is 'it depends.' We actually
have to change the way we think about each
other, the way to relate to each other, and
then try to solve the problems. Ah-I think
we're still courting some old paradigms. Maybe
the crisis needs to deepen before we have
that dialog.
But-ah-I think there's enough people moving
in that direction and I'm positive about that.
Ah-and I think it will push us probably to
solving the problems we've been talking about
and not getting around-climate change and
the like. There we are.